un jeune homme de 25 ans est décédé
d'une overdose hier à valence un autre
lutte toujours contre la mort à
l'hôpital précisément la chronique
médicale de jacques vaudou est consacrée
au rôle essentiel de l'hôpital qui dans
une ville comme privat fait face par
exemple aux besoins de 30 à 40 mille
habitants et cela malgré les difficultés
budgétaires
l'hôpital public est-il irremplaçable
oui d'après cette enquête menée à
l'hôpital général de privas
irremplaçable car ivan une population de
30 à 40 mille habitants où irait les
patients sinon à 48 50 kilomètres avant
de trouver un lieu de soins ouvert à
toute heure du jour et de l'indus mais
que ne dit on pas sur l'hôpital public
il y aurait paraît-il 2700 postes
vacants faute de trouver du personnel à
privas en ennemi qu'il manque quelques
poches notamment un manipulateur radio
et un chirurgien orthopédique
on a du mal à en trouver sont peut-être
un peu moins attirés vers l'hopital
public qu'il ya quelques années mais
reste je crois a tiré par des conditions
de pratique médicale ou chirurgicale un
plateau technique et les conditions de
réalisation de la médecine qu'on trouve
qu'à l'hôpital public beaux mouvements
mais c'est pas le salaire qu'ils et hier
c'est non à vrai dire ce n'est pas le
salaire qui les attire on ne vient pas
forcément à l'hôpital pour donner de
l'argent ou pour faire fortune mais on y
vient pour une certaine qualité de son
exercice professionnel non l'hôpital
fonctionne 95% des interventions
chirurgicales y sont possibles quant au
service des urgences ne pas en pauvre de
l'hôpital public
c'est un souci permanent pour le corps
médical
jusqu'à maintenant ces services étaient
parfois un peu délaissé par les jeunes
étudiants ou les jeunes internes et nous
nous retrouvions où ils se retrouvaient
par hasard des gens qui étaient
peut-être pas les plus aguerris pour
faire ce métier
un pas les plus aguerris depuis quelques
années les gens sont bien formés à mon
avis mais pas les plus aguerris et donc
nous avons avec le directeur d'hôpital
général de privas ici et après un
certain nombre de constatations décidé
nous d'y mettre des médecins a guéri
sous forme de transformation de poste et
d'y mettre des médecins assistants qui
sont sous contrat avec nous
plutôt guillemette des internes qui
choisissent parce qu'en général c'est
choisisse ses services n'étaient pas
choisi en premier reste l'attribution
d'un scanner un appareil d'investigation
très coûteux il est vrai que l'on a
servi en priorité les grands hôpitaux
universitaires et dans un hôpital
général de 258 s1 appareils rentables
mais peut-on parler de rentabilité en
médecine
oui il manque c'est à dire que pour
l'utilité pas pour eux pas pour faire
vingt malades par jour
point de vue population utilité c'est
évident que au lieu de faire 40
kilomètres pour aller à valence ayant
préféré la voir sur place quant aux
réformes hospitalières qui se succèdent
environ tous les deux ans et selon les
ministres on est un peu plus sceptique
on vous répond que l'hôpital avance par
la force des choses avec ou sans réforme
hospitalière à privas et dans les
structures de cette dimension
on n'a pas l'impression que ce soit des
réformes qui vont permettre de mieux
soigner les personnes mais certainement
qu'il faut continuellement améliorer la
santé l'outil de production
l'outil de soins au niveau national avec
un budget de 100 millions de francs par
an et 6500 personnes hospitalisées dans
l'année peu de récriminations
d'après un sondage réalisé après vingt
deux points positive
l'accueil chaleureux et la compétence de
médecins le public souhaite seulement
des attentes moins longues et l'achat
d'un scanner pour ne pas être obligé
d'aller à valence